let's see if we can evaluate the
definite integral from 11 PI over 2 to 6
PI of 9 sine of X DX so the first thing
let's see if we can take the
antiderivative of 9 sine of X so we
could use some of our integration
properties to simplify this a little bit
so this is going to be equal to this is
the same thing as 9 times the integral
from 11 PI over 2 to 6 pi of sine of X
DX and what's the antiderivative sine of
X well we know from our derivatives that
the derivative with respect to X of
cosine of X is equal to is equal to
negative sine of X negative sine of X so
can we construct this in some way so
this is a negative sine of X what if I
multiplied it on the inside what if I
multiplied it by a negative 1 well I
can't just multiply it only one place by
negative 1 I need to multiply by
negative 1 twice so I'm not changing its
value so what if I said negative 9 times
negative sine of X well this is still
going to be 9 sine of X if you took
negative 9 times negative sine of X it
is 9 sine of X and I did it this way
because now negative sine of X it
matches the derivative of cosine of X so
we could say that this is all going to
be equal to it's all going to be equal
to you have your negative 9 out front
negative 9 times x and I'll put it in
put it in brackets negative 9 times the
antiderivative of negative sine of X
well that is just going to be cosine of
X cosine of X and we're going to
evaluate it at its bounds we're going to
evaluate it at 6 PI and we do that in a
color I haven't used yet we're going to
do that at 6 pi and we're also going to
do that at 11 PI over 2 11 PI over 2 and
so this is going to be equal to this is
equal to negative 9 times I'm going to
create some space here so actually I
probably more space than I need it's
going to
cosine of 6 pi cosine of 6 6 pi cosine
of 6 PI - minus cosine of 11 PI over 2
cosine of 11 PI over 2 well what is
cosine of 6 pi going to be well cosine
of any multiple of 2 pi is going to be
equal to 1 you could view 6 PI as we're
going around the unit circle 3 times so
this is the same thing as cosine of 2 pi
or the same thing as cosine of 0 so that
is going to be equal to 1 if that seems
unfamiliar to you I encourage you to
review the unit circle definition of
cosine and what is cosine of 11 PI over
2 let's see let's subtract some let's
subtract some multiple of 2 pi here to
put it in values that we can understand
better so this is so let me write it
here cosine of 11 PI over 2 that is the
same thing as let's see if we were to
subtract this is the same thing as
cosine of 11 PI over 2
- let's see this is the same thing as 5
and 1/2 pi right yeah so this is so we
could view this as we could subtract
let's subtract 4 pi which is going to be
we could write that as 8 PI over 2 in
fact now let's subtract 5 let's subtract
now let's subtract 4 pi which is 8 PI
over 2 so once again I'm just
subtracting a multiple of 2 pi which
isn't going to change the value of
cosine and so this is going to be equal
to cosine of 3 PI over 2 and if we
imagine the unit circle let me draw the
unit circle here so it's my y-axis my
x-axis and then I have the unit circle
so whoops all right the unit circle just
like that so if we start at this is 0
then you go
two PI over two then you go to PI then
you go to three PI over two so that's
this point on the unit circle so the
cosine is the x-coordinate so this is
going to be zero this is zero so this is
zero and so we get one minus zero so
everything in the brackets evaluates out
to one and so we are left with so let me
do that so all of this is equal to one
and so you have negative 9 times 1 which
of course is just negative 9 is what
this definite integral evaluates to